grande não obrigado
bom primeiro lugar gostaria de agradecer
a deus e agradecer à minha família
porque a experiência que vivi pessoa que
eu era a pessoa que sou eu devo
exclusivamente a deus as minhas força ea
minha família agradeceu ted x por me
convidar a participar desta palestra por
onde está passando homens e mulheres
extraordinárias propositores idealistas
e que estão preocupadas com a
coletividade com a sociedade não todos é
interessante
bom eu vou falar sobre diferente tipo de
resíduos aos resíduos inertes papéis
plásticos metais alumínio aos resíduos
líquidos óleos motores óleos industriais
óleos vegetais e resíduos orgânicos que
são os restos de nosso detritos e restos
de trânsito de animais resto de comida
já de verduras e que é um malefício
extraordinário para toda a sociedade pra
mim pra você independente do território
a gente mora independente da classe
social independente do poder aquisitivo
os resíduos
eles são gerados em todo canto da cidade
em todo canto do planeta assim posso
dizer mas os dados mostram que os
grandes volumes de resíduos
ele vem de dentro da favela de dentro
das comunidades oriundo de uma delas e
existem outros tipos de resíduos que
flui do ventre da pátria amada mãe
gentil e que poucas pessoas estão
preocupadas com a logística reversa
desse tipo de resíduo resíduo é uma
situação eu vivi essa situação me
identifiquei resíduos
conquistei força de apoio familiar
no entanto estou aqui falando do
complexo do alemão dos diferentes tipos
de resíduos que geram e de acordo com os
dados que temos noventa e uma toneladas
de resíduos são gerados diariamente
nós olhamos os resíduos como um grande
problema e sim é o lugar onde ele está
disposto
se olharmos com outros olhos
podemos ver nos resíduos um outro tipo
de potencial dessas 91 a tonelada de
resíduos que são geradas no complexo do
alemão e que são gerados em outras
comunidades no planeta num todo
nós temos 54 pontos e 60% de orgânico
maléfico agressor porque ele emite
metano constantemente é matéria prima
para a produção de um tijolo de um
tijolo ecológico que deveria estar
transitando entre você e eu trouxe mas
acabei deixando o tijolo aqui atrás esse
percentual de orgânico maléfico que cria
dentro dos dutos cidades para diferentes
vetores e que vivem ali atraindo para o
nosso meio diferente tipo de doenças
os gastos em saúde outras coisas à
margem da apresentação esses pontos que
o tempo é curto mas temos que olhar esse
resíduo com uma matéria prima que se
preocupar com a sua destinação legal e
correta ou gentileza obrigado amigo
os outros percentuais o plástico aqui
tem um jogo tá processo com links ele
tem 37% de algodão é papel-moeda da casa
da moeda é um tipo de resíduo que ele
tem que ser bem destinado eu gostaria
que vocês pudessem tocar e passassem de
um irmão a tiro na cabeça de ninguém não
favor gente dos plásticos
quais são os tipos de utensílios que nós
temos que é oriundo do plástico quase
todos quase todos o fone de ouvido a
capa do laptop uma série de outras
coisas e que hoje a gente continua ou na
verdade as grandes indústrias continua
fazendo extração de recursos naturais
quanto que a gente poderia voltar pra
esse jogo
que já estão aí causando um grande
problema gerando uma série de malefícios
atraindo vetores atraindo doença gerando
custos enormes né fazer a destinação
legal desse registo fazer a logística
reversa dos resíduos de maneira sócio
ambiental envolvendo inserindo pessoas a
mesma coisa papéis
tudo que é possível ser produzido a
partir do papel a gente não precisa
estar distraindo tantas árvores na
amazônia como nós estamos traindo está
tendo um problema de aquecimento preciso
ficar citando que já foi citado aqui
todo malefício que vem a partir da
região quero focar nos benefícios
resido humano quando emitir essa
expressão teve uma pessoa que me
criticou
mas essa mesma pessoa que eu não vou
citar o nome ou a companhia no final de
uma palestra ea gente encontrou algumas
pessoas na porta daquele espaço e essa
pessoa que me criticou sua expressão
daquela maneira ela traz o lula deu a
volta pra não passar por um andarilho
pra não passar por um catador para não
passar por um mendigo por uma pessoa em
situação de rua são dois caminhos o que
você sabe
em relação a essa pessoa que foi essa
pessoa chegar naquela situação foi o
descaminho eu vivi o meu descaminho hoje
totalmente encaminhado e tentando
replicar a oportunidade de
encaminhamento para outras pessoas
a pessoa que me criticou muito obrigado
a pessoa que me criticou ela
sinceramente ela deu a volta e eu fiquei
observando no final fui falar com ela a
cara e é por isso que eu falei que
resida eu vivi a experiência de êxito
tem muitas pessoas vivendo a experiência
desse resíduo e nós formados consciente
de uma série de coisas mundo afora a
gente não consegue tratar aquela pessoa
como um semelhante como o ser humano não
consegue é pelo o do e pela maneira que
está vestida por estar em situação de
rua por uma série de outras situações
então a gente repete aquela pessoa gente
não absolve aquela pessoa vezes numa
troca de palavras gente muda o ritmo de
caminhada aquela pessoa depende da
maneira com que a gente olha depende da
maneira com que a gente vai receber essa
pessoa
gente eu estive no entanto pode ser
difícil mas não é impossível que se
fosse eu não estaria aqui
e não sou eu o único exemplo há vários
outros exemplos
a gente precisa criar a estrutura que
possibilite a logística reversa do ser
humano
existem projetos de preservação de
trocentas espécies que estão em extinção
existe hoje o projeto da política
nacional de resíduos sólidos que visa a
logística reversa dos resíduos a
responsabilidade compartilhada
o resto é tudo aquilo que nós consumimos
fazer com que jesus volte é a logística
reversa dos resíduos e o ser humano onde
é que está
quando se descobre potencial de recursos
embutidos e resíduos surge alguém com
poder de capital para poder controlar o
processo e que o equipamento gigante que
tenham menos pessoas envolvidas no
processo nós precisamos inserir as
pessoas no processo
precisamos ser sócio e ambiental de fato
para que a gente possa fazer com que
esses resíduos humanos voltem a ser
seres humanos que eles possam ser
reinseridos na sociedade inseridos no
mercado de trabalho e possam pagar os
seus impostos a partir da labuta de suas
mãos
essa frase é para que a gente possa
refletir e isso é fato quando uma pessoa
tem fome a gente tem que alimentar como
uma pessoa tem ser urgente que levará
água a empurrar o inimigo de si uma
saída se sentir totalmente encurralados
lutaram até à morte o assunto usuário da
guerra
existem vários tipos de resistência onde
a minha resistência a uma existência
social propositiva em cima de uma coisa
que todos viram como um problema e eu
olho com outro tipo de olhar e consigo
ver solução
no entanto careira e dizer em cima desse
texto essa frase é que existem pessoas
resistindo de maneira armada de maneira
primitiva o falta de consciência humana
daqueles que estão no poder
nós temos uma proposta nós temos um
projeto eu me rendi seria eu me
reintegrei a partir da coleta de óleo
vegetal do alto da família consome isso
toda a família gera resíduo a gente tem
que olhar os egípcios com matéria prima
para a geração de trabalho e renda para
a reintegração social das pessoas
de produzir matéria-prima para toda a
indústria está consumindo está extraindo
no lugar errado está extraindo dos
recursos naturais está fazendo a questão
do aquecimento a gente trazendo a
questão da água do desemprego da fome da
miséria existe uma mensagem de que
teremos já foi anunciado
não sei dizer quantos anos de que
teremos mil anos de paz mas onde haverá
paz com tanta miséria com tanta fome com
tanta desigualdade
nós temos um sonho é a proposta do
resíduo por vidas não ser manipulado por
quem tem mais recursos mais ser
manipulado por aquele que quer
distribuir o recurso para que a gente
possa fazer pessoas reincidirem as suas
casas
fazer pessoas relatarem os seus laços
familiares ea partir daí a gente podia
fazer outro tipo de intervenção que são
necessárias dos resíduos que nós já
citamos aqui
o tesouro está transitando por aí eu
espero que as pessoas estejam apreciando
a um tijolo já patenteado e aprovado
pela brt já de acordo com o instituto de
microbiologia da comlurb ele é comparado
a água que a gente bebe independente de
ser extraído dos lixões
independente de ter sido um resíduo um
dia este jogo hoje é para ninguém passar
a língua mas ele é comparada ao que a
gente bebe pra entender não acredito que
alguém com sede em frente pra pensar
diferente tipo de resíduos que são
gerados dentro das comunidades dentro da
cidade a gente temos o pet aqui 14%
tempo daquela 91 a tonelada de resíduos
se nós conseguimos coletar todo os
plásticos são gerados dentro daquele
complexo a gente chega no montante de 1
milhão e 500 mil e receita
aproximadamente quantas pessoas são
beneficiadas em trabalho e renda com
esse volume de recursos a gente precisa
envolver as pessoas
a gente está utilizando muitas
tecnologias e eliminando as pessoas aqui
que a gente está fazendo tirar essas
pessoas das áreas de insalubridade qual
estavam vivendo e elas estão migrando
para os grandes centros se tornando
naquilo que muitos chamam de poluição
visual se transformando e população em
situação de rua e pessoas com problemas
de bebida com problemas de drogas porque
porque nós estamos excluindo eles cada
vez mais dos seus direitos
um outro tipo de resíduo que ele é
gerado em grande volume porém ele tem um
valor muito baixo é o vidro mas por
conta do consumo de bebida as favelas
estão virando um monte de pires de
vidros de garrafas
no entanto um quilo desse mesmo vidro
hoje ele é aproximadamente um raio 40 um
raio 50 200 gramas dessas mil grama
transformado num tem cílios posso vender
por cinco reais ou por r$10 e agregar
mais de 40 mil por cento de valor em
cima desse resíduo foi 200 duzentas
gramas de mil gramas sobrou 800 gramas
se criar outros utensílios de
aproximadamente 200 gramas e é
transformar esse jesus numa nova num
novo produto nova matéria se utilizada
na questão do orgânico além de destinar
corretamente um resíduo que ele é danoso
à toda a sociedade
nós estaremos preservando a árvores na
amazônia porque os métodos de construção
hoje por parte das construtoras consome
muita madeira madeira papo na madeira
paulo na madeira madeira madeira
extração tempo todo e depois é tudo
jogado fora
nada é reaproveitar a gente precisa
iniciar um novo processo de extração é
reaproveitar os resíduos que geramos ao
invés de arrumar um lugar pra empunhando
tanto resíduos é a gente reaproveita e
transformar num produto começar a
construir produzir 'tijolos' ea partir
destes jogos construir casas temos um
déficit habitacional
muitas pessoas vivendo em condições
difíceis por conta desse processo os
resíduos não só estão dentro das favelas
estão dentro das lições tem um dado aqui
que eu preciso planejar ele os resíduos
plásticos duros e moles 62 milhões
quatrocentos e sessenta milhões e 250
mil toneladas
essa é uma china é uma estimativa de
1999 a 2011
a fonte é carvalho 2009
são matérias primas para se produzir
tudo e qualquer coisa que seja de
plástico organo terroso matéria prima
para se produzir tijolos em volumes
gerando porte trabalho sustentáveis para
se produzir casas para combater
efe habitacional para combater a
desigualdade no qual nós vivemos para
gerar postos de trabalho para interferir
nas comunidades com renda em parceria
com empresas que estavam cumprindo a sua
logística reversa e aí nós
interferiremos dessa forma na saúde que
têm um gasto exorbitante porque
estaremos direcionando corretamente os
resíduos
traremos para a sociedade qualidade de
vida educação porque sem educação nada
disso acontece segurança porque porque
estaremos fazendo a reintegração do ser
humano
estaremos fazendo a logística reversa
das pessoas que estão descaminho snu
interessa minha você o porquê o
descaminho que interessa aqui é um
semelhante que nós temos que trazer ele
pra dentro do processo novamente se não
um dia ele vai bater à minha porta ou à
sua porta
logística reversa dos resíduos sólidos
dos resíduos orgânicos ea logística
reversa do ser humano e nada disso
acontecerá se nós não estivermos juntos
não cooperarmos mutuamente um culto de
todos os problemas que aqui foram
citados o problema não está nas
organizações na zona indígena no
município no estado eo governo federal
estão nas pessoas porque atrás de cada
uma das organizações têm pessoas
então o que precisa mudar são as pessoas
nós precisamos mudar nossa maneira de
ser
nós precisamos mudar o nosso
comportamento a nossa atitude e os
nossos atos nós precisamos nos reciclar
para ser um novo ser
é parte do novo ser que seremos aí nós
iremos ver se refletir na sociedade e no
mundo como um todo e eu fico por aqui
agradeço a oportunidade